guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters
inshallah help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast this is a
picture this picture was sent to me um
and uh panel as you can see on a prayer
map now when you zoom in a bit
down this is the executive executive
produced the producers yeah
it is him and then he writes and allah
and to put allah's glorious name in
there is an absolute insult
now this is where it gets a little bit
disturbing because now there's two
options you give this
person now deja had you have two options
number one
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends before i start one praise
allah the most merciful the most trust
or praise is glory and gratitude belong
to him
i'm gonna get straight into this
inshallah so this was sent to me a uh
by somebody and as you guys can see on
the screen
this is a picture this picture was sent
to me um and uh
as you can see he's on a prayer map he's
got his two sons there he's got his
hands in a dua
uh position that's how we as muslims
make dua we use the prayer mat to praise
salah the actual prayer five
times the day that we need to pray and
um
we obviously can make prayers as well
one day as well and uh we
we ask god almighty we don't go to jesus
we don't go to muhammad peace be upon
them
we don't go to someone else we go
directly to the one who's created us and
this is what
islam is all about so now when i see
this i'm like okay
it seems like someone he's in the music
in the street and he's someone that sins
uh like we all do but he's since opening
the public etc
uh this is shortcoming you know cetera
it doesn't notify him to be a muslim
um but the and and that's what i can see
i can see someone that's you know
maybe repenting maybe um wants to get uh
closer to god almighty but the thing is
this
the next picture gets a little bit
disturbing because there that's where
we're like
there's two possibilities to this thing
now when we zoom into this here
this is the tracks that he's uh made
this is album that is released okay
now when you zoom in a bit down
is this is the executive executive
produced
uh the producers yeah by asa ashant
khalid i'm sure it's a family member
same sermon surname
yeah uh maybe as well i don't know
khalid
is him and then he writes and allah now
this is
where it gets a little bit disturbing
because now there's two options you give
this uh person
now do you have two options number one
is that you
are you're in a you think
there's a bit of a delusion you think
that allah is pleased with what you're
doing
now that is a big delusion and there
will be many people who will come and i
think it's a quran i can't remember
where
allah says many people come that they
even think that
they did a lot of good deeds but it will
go to knowledge and it's not
turned into something on those lines
yeah now
you know and i know yeah now we can say
there's an argument about
let's say music yeah and there isn't
your type of music 100 is not
permissible the under 100 billion
percent is optimistic either i don't
think anyone that believes me is
permissible
scholars will be what uh your the music
that you do or produce
is permissible vulgar all kinds of
magnets all kinds of
filthy i'm so sorry yeah then you have
naked girls
naked girls like naked girls yeah okay
um and then you're talking about
violence you're talking about some
you know it can be satanic stuff etc all
kinds of crazy stuff okay
the lifestyle that you live yeah okay
that there is
in jahlia i used to see certain things
which very disturbing
you know they're very very disturbing
stuff outright you know public and
full out i can't go into detail yeah um
yeah mad stuff anyways i don't want to
get the detail yeah so either
you're a muslim still you know what
you're doing is wrong
uh and that is still wrong you need to
change your ways and
repent to god almighty or there's
another option where you
are outright um doing this to mock the
dean
now when you write produced by allah
that's one of the two options
insurance i want to give the benefit now
there's the two options i could have
gone to the second option straight away
but look at the all right mocking the
deep
yeah produced by allah let me tell you
what's produced by allah allah subhana
wa
says verse 119.
[Music]
[Music]
indeed in the creations of the heavens
and the earth and in the alternation of
the night and day
there are signs for those who have
intellect those who believe
the night and the universe the creation
of heavens and the earth um
and in the alternation of the nineteen
that's what allah produced that's what
allah has made
allah subhanahu wa tala has also made
you khalid allah has made you
please send this video to him you know
why because guys
you need to understand if you genuinely
believe that this is what is going to be
pleasing to allah
shaytan has deluded you big time big
time
so brother khalid you're still a muslim
brother yeah we're going to go with the
first option that you
are under the assumption that allah
pleased with this and to put allah's
name into something like this which is
absolutely
filth let's be real it's filth it's
nothing but filth yeah it's it's
it's nothing but you know the industry
that you push the stuff that you do etc
it's wrong and to put allah's glorious
name
in there is an absolute insult it's an
absolute insult and if you're doing this
out of ignorance
please fix your ways if you're doing
this to mock the dean
this will render someone out of the fold
of islam if you're intentionally doing
this
and brother and sister this is where we
need to be very careful and brother
khalid
still still and i want to end on that
i've got much really say tell this
matter
it's sad to see that you're a muslim
alhamdulillah you should
really be proud of your religion but to
put allah's name there as a producer
allah did not produce that
allah created the heavens and the earth
allah created this earth allah created
you
allah created your children allah
created everything every breath that you
take
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has created
you and it's upon you to do good or bad
that's upon you but to ascribe allah to
the
mistake that you're doing and allah this
is lie
this is not true yeah and uh
but still even then whatever you have
committed allah's mercy is open
and even then brother khalid yeah you
still if if we've got the first option
you know
you're doing it because you do not know
allah's mercy is open
and allah says um
verse 53 i would be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do not despair the mercy of allah
for allah forgives all sins for he is of
forgiven
most merciful and this goes to everybody
out there brothers and sisters
who may feel like they have sinned
they've wronged themselves
never despair the mercy of allah your
lord is mostly given most mercy for he
wants you to turn to him
in repentance and we know from the
hadith of the prophet said to us
that allah said if the sins of
adam was to reach the mountains in the
skies i will forgive
every single one of them as long as they
do not associate partners to me
brothers and sisters please share this
with us maybe this one inshallah i'll be
some kind of an essay to him in ramadan
may allah bless every single one of you
guys inshaallah and in this ramadan
inshallah please do check out
the very next video of qurani app which
you can get a connection with the quran
like you have never before inshallah
and download that right now enjoy your
free seven day trial inshallah sisters
may allah bless you guys
and may allah keep us on the stalking